I remember when Disney didn't try to
blow themselves during each opening
movie logo if the Santa Claus had come
out these days they'd put the magic
kingdom castle in the middle of the
North Pole
like hot rods and calendars with women
in bikinis scattered around it to appeal
to Tim Allen's demographic what the hell
kind of Christmas party is this
everyone's on different floors
celebrating within the 36 inches between
the offices and the railing it's like
this was held in a king Embassy Suites
Scott Calvin and Susan Perry you can
tell how useless all this setup is by
the fact that they do it during the
opening credits do you really need to
know who was responsible for the 4q
Midwest revenue growth this year viewer
you do not but our families aren't here
with us right now it's just probably why
I Johnson secretary citizens laugh
casual office adultery weird 90s creep
also I know corporate dudes use people's
last names a lot but that Scott really
called us dude Johnson and firm this
large I refuse to believe there's only
one mother with that super common
surname also also these two minutes of
party shenanigans still manage to be
funnier than the entirety of office
Christmas party a full minute of
Christmas caroling to finish off the
opening credits after we've already gone
through the opening the chose what an
asshole Scott is also just in case the
title of the film didn't give away the
holiday theme movie hits the audience
over the head with Christmas so hard in
the first three minutes that we all need
eggnog ice packs Judge Reinhold isn't
masturbating to an imaginary Phoebe
Cates in the scene also just three years
prior Chuck ride home probably would
have been the lead in this film but now
he's playing second fiddle to the guy
from home improvement I'd like to
believe that that is the inspirational
juice he's putting behind the sarcastic
wait I remember how charming Tim Allen
was back in the day really besides Buzz
Lightyear
this was every fucking character he did
hey crass dickhead that says whatever he
wants and thinks he's super funny that
eventually turns out to have a heart and
who gave you permission to tell Charlie
there's no Santa Claus
considering how loud Scott is talking
right now he's pretty much taking care
of that himself
if we're gonna destroy our son's
illusions I should be a part of it yeah
but you're never around
Oh oh please I really want to say that
liar liar ripped this movie off three
years later but since it's so much
better than this I choose to believe
that liar liar was in development for
many years and this movie ripped it off
I realize
1994 Disney isn't 2018 Disney but
Denny's was the best product placement
time they could get for a big holiday
film hope they didn't cater the set as
well moons over Miami is literally the
gift that keeps on giving
oh talk about please world fame knocks
Jesus Christ even though I know all this
turns out ok I feel bad for this kid
super tonight
so I'm gonna sin the movie anyway you
know they got hot apple then maybe not
be a dick and take the fucking sign down
Denny's yo Sam's been at this a long
time and has to have encountered a
parent discovering him before especially
if he's making this much noise this fall
is total amateur hour
also that roofs like 18 20 feet off the
ground if the Dark Knight taught me
anything and it's taught me plenty
including how to kill someone with a
pencil it's the falling from a couple
stories up won't kill you if Santa had
broken his legs and couldn't complete
the voyage that would make a lot more
sense mm-hmm yep he's done killed Santa
and if the movie took a hard left turn
into a horror movie from this point on
and I'd be much more interested man
Charlie's displaying some disturbing
blood lust in his early years something
should happen to me put on my suit the
reindeer will know what to do seems like
a pretty important piece of info to just
have half a stuffed in a coat also this
is Santa's contingency plan just hand
over the job to any Tim Dick or Harry
that happens to be around during his
death this is less practical than giving
singular authority over the American
nuke codes to one highly unstable person
I understand not everyone in this condo
complex would wake up when Santa landed
but it's gotten curly it made a lot of
noise out here oh why isn't that waking
anyone else up I look forward to the end
of the movie when after defeating the
Empire Scott will be visited by Santa's
force ghost who will be beaming with
pride Charlie come on down from there
actually yeah that group is super steep
covered with snow and has already killed
a person today whoa this guy was huge
Santa Shamy this was the night before
Christmas the man standing last was
convinced to play Santa by a rogue
reindeers gas let's go since the card
said Scott had to put the suit on and
the reindeer would know what to do why
are they doing anything if he doesn't
have a suit on I might believe in Santa
but his instructions aren't worth all so
how many kids have been skipped due to
this whole situation I mean I know
Santa's magic and all of it he's also
got a very tight window to squeeze the
gift delivery into so I'm just gonna
assume the entire country of Botswana
has now been missed is up with these
affect you might say it's only 1994 but
then I would say only 3 years removed
from t2
one year removed from Jurassic Park so
golf stupid passive-aggression nubs off
out here which seems like yet another
great reason to put the fucking suit on
this movie is taking way too long to
Santa Claus
movie is presenting us with a world
where Santa exists but the parents
believe that he doesn't so where the
fuck do they think these toys come from
for their kids every Christmas there's
no chimney here look I can maybe buy
that the entire complex where Scott
lives was on quaaludes or some but
they're making a tremendous amount of
noise here and the guy next door is
already awakened armed where's his ass
Oh got a terrible parent lets their kids
sleep on the couch in the same room is
the tree on Christmas Eve hey whatever
happened to the rain forests that was a
big deal in the 90s but you never really
hear about them today I think good now
dude Fern Gully and medicine man really
turn the tide in that battle I guess
movie saying that Scott and Charlie
successfully delivered gifts to the
Chicagoland area
is that it I'm not glum South Africa
Taiwan are they all screwed we're done
comic Oh Tim Allen just disappears into
this role doesn't he honestly thought
Scott was being played by Ellen when the
first time I saw this well I appreciate
good subterfuge as much as the next guy
I don't understand why you need it all
the way out in the North Pole who else
would be around to discover all this I
guess the elves are excited that
Christmas is done but did no one give a
shit about the last Santa he's fucking
dead man doesn't anyone want to say a
few words or something does this happen
all the time I thought I told you to
stay in the sleigh this this brings up
an interesting question
the new Santa is required to take over
for the old Santa but if the new Santa
has like a really important job that
saves a lot of lives he's gotta leave
that also what if he's taken over by a
woman or a kid see twas all about the
mrs. Claus so what would happen then my
point is that everyone involved with
this movie was way too busy handling
that mountain of cocaine and putting any
actual thought into the script
Oh Larry take Charlie here and get him
some chow strangers with candy
then you're the new Santa and putting on
the Hat jacket you accepted the contract
this is a tough way to run a popular
holiday man also Scott doesn't
immediately tell him that he didn't wear
the hat just the jacket so the contract
is null and void Tim the tool man you
better come take a look at this cliche
you leave tomorrow morning
you have 11 months to get your affairs
in order and you're due back here
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving I mean that's
awfully kind of them to give him some
time to say goodbye but isn't
Thanksgiving cutting it a little close
to be cramming for a full Santa itch
next year also why does the David
Krumholtz elf character have dreadlocks
I mean I guess it worked for endurance
but 1994 was weird dude you sleep
yeah but the Sun was already coming up
in Chicago when they flew by and that
had to have been several hours ago even
though the North Pole is constantly dark
in the winter it doesn't mean it's
actually nighttime then Charlie's mom
said she was picking him up super early
on Christmas Day just because there's
magic here doesn't mean you can dr.
strange the time line damn it why are
Scott's pajamas a perfect fit we've seen
that sound off that was huge on it and
Judy definitely gave him official
Santa's PJ's did the original Santa
squeeze his fat ass into these things I
see it I don't believe it really because
I can totally believe this isn't
obviously painted backdrop you're
looking at damn it I've heard kids more
excited about describing a trip to the
grocery store how the hell does charlie
state this so matter-of-factly seen us
off the roof and dad wrong so I'm not
sure exactly how old Charlie's supposed
to be but I am sure he's at least my mom
and stepfather aren't going to believe
me when I tell them dad's the new Santa
years old go first that's how you feel
Charlie what kind of monster kid invites
three of his parents for career day
letting at least two of them present is
he trying to mock the other kids from
single-parent households also isn't the
whole thing about Scott that he's
distant and never there
but he's here in midday at school for
career day Bobby we don't say stupid and
we don't say elves there are little
people I almost want to take us in away
for the masterful casting of Mary gross
but then I'd have to be that guy that
took a fucking sin away from the Santa
Clause so I am a doctor no he's not he's
a psychiatrist this movie really makes
me realize how many jokes were mined out
of the he's not a real doctor trope
dentist dermatologist psychiatrists
Plastic Surgeons podiatrists they're all
apparently open game for comedy gold
serious question was this look this
popular in 1994 or was it a pure
accident that Wendy Crewson looks
exactly like looma Thurman in Pulp
Fiction
I don't what you are dad did the elf
seriously not make any attempts to
follow up with Scott after Christmas
sure they're letting him get his affairs
in order
but he's a brand new fucking Santa man
at least sent him the manual to start
reviewing after he gets back how can one
man in one night is that all the
children of the world I think there's
some sort of time continuum that breaks
down what sirs gonna slay just go ahead
and say Yatta Yatta kid not for santa
himself just for this movie
you're not listening we are very
concerned about this concerned about
what I got a side with Scot in this case
Charlie as a young kid was a very
healthy and active imagination there had
to be many more interesting directions
that could have taken this story instead
of just sticking with the concerned non
believing parents storyline that even
sitcoms at this time would have avoided
we've got to talk about the Santa Claus
thing actually you can you do a lot less
talking after they get back from the
North Pole they go through this is it
real thing for King ever and I'm afraid
we've already exceeded our unnecessary
fart quota for the movie folks
what's a dose II 15 sins as a fare
penalty yeah oh yeah remember that super
important job that dominated Scots life
but we haven't seen a man for the last
half of the movie seriously how long has
it been since these assholes have seen
him oh we had to is develop a basic
simple inexpensive toy Calvin can I see
you outside a minute he's making balls
pissed he's tanking his price you're
gonna find out who the fraudulent types
and a Scot he sucks with this crowd I
don't know what's happening to you
they're starting to look like the
Pillsbury Doughboy
that's pastry sister I shave in the
morning never noon I look like this
could be a hormonal imbalance could be
that this guy needs to give his medical
degree back why would Santa's heart play
jingle bells based on what happened at
the beginning of the film it's clear
that Santa can die from falling off a
roof so wouldn't all his internal organs
act like a normal person's would and the
parents of the Year award goes to the
folks in this park who allow their kids
to go up to a bearded stranger and sit
on his lap with no supervision the scene
could be best described as peak 90s
jeans this list wait but didn't Barnard
tell him that he had to put a put a pea
neck so that kids were nice and see next
to the naughty ones because this looks
like he just checks off a box seems like
Scott could just let Neil and Laura
witness the transformation firsthand and
there would be no familial issues for
the rest of the movie you wouldn't even
need to cast a custody judge
I got dozens of presents oh I got
everything except a mystery date I'm
sorry miss but you must have
accidentally wandered off the set of the
movie that actually required you to act
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave
all of your visitation rights
suspended pending a hearing after the
first of the year hey you know what I
like in my Christmas movies child
custody drama that's why I always pop in
my copy of Kramer vs Kramer at the
beginning of December single white Santa
Charlie he's not Santa
fucking Neil even though dad essentially
kidnapped kid and scares the fuck out of
the mother everything will work out okay
in the end and all will be forgiven
cliche fireplaces will no longer be a
problem were they a problem before
presenting this like they've had a
technological breakthrough but the
preferred method of santa's entry has
always been the fireplace right so why
is this needed at all but you thought
this movie was a lot better than it
actually is I know I did hang on Bernard
explicitly told Scott that he had to
report by Thanksgiving the movies zipper
right through the last bit since they've
been at the North Pole like it's been a
couple days max so what side of the
Charlie been missing from his mother for
a fucking month or they fucked up this
timeline and either way it's sinfully
why is everyone wearing protective
goggles it's not as if flames are going
to come out of the back of Santa's
sleigh
the usual Santa specs Chinese checkers
considering no one is supposed to see
Santa a lot of people see Santa in this
movie Jesus Christ
stop letting this kid sleep in the
living room right by the tree I know
it's like you're once again staying in
the city limits of Chicago for this
entire night you'll be okay kids isn't
it supposed to be super late at night
Santa has already made several
deliveries so what's up with these fully
clothed children that are up and out on
the fucking Street so no one's gonna
check on the roof just for some giggles
and Scott told none that's where charlie
is okay guess not carry on their whole
thing it's not being detected right
discount Dennis grunts we're not kids
I'm not visiting I mean technically one
of you was a kid but semantics but they
literally just said the house was still
under police surveillance Jesus
everything about this final act is the
bothius bullshit that ever you know
helped make me sad so really this whole
mandatory separation from your father
thing is all your fault okay good talk
Merry Christmas
I love you son so are Neil and Laura
just cool with Scott now just a few
hours ago they had his ass arrested
they're good with all this playing out
why the custody papers I want you to
come and see Charlie as often as you can
that's how the legal system works manic
devoting a lot of police force of this
nonviolent Ally suspect to hasn't been
proven to have done anything criminal
what is this the fucking Blues Brothers
tip well don't just stand there
fire it will me Santa don't you have
places to be Charlie upon recovering
their only son who's been presumably
missing for the last several weeks Laura
and Neal's first move was to let him
stand outside by himself in the snow for
quite some time
Oh judgement is nigh but that Belsnickel
is eyes yes he is finally nigh and I
want you to ram stock down your clients
throats until they can choke on it shall
they choke on it
why isn't he coming tonight not
necessarily Jerry enjoy my wife did you
see that yes the Frog is certainly
taking a beating on this show I have a
friend who works at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art how'd you like a
behind-the-scenes tour really you could
do that easily how can one man in one
night visit all the children of the
world
[Music]
Christmas magic I know who you are but I
heard you were dead I could put you in
Queens on the night of the hijacking
really I live in Queens did you put that
together yourself Einstein but he got a
team of monkeys working around the clock
on this